all right one more Trump thing before we
move on to other things Donald Trump
published a statement yesterday in which
he demands that Mike Pence actually be
investigated for not stealing the
election now there's a really great
article in Vanity Fair from best Levin
about this where she describes uh she
did she describes Trump's statement as
febrile and grammatically offensive
which is maybe the best way to describe
any Trump statement that I've ever heard
and we're going to look at that
statement in a moment I encourage you to
actually read the article from by best
Levin in Vanity Fair uh but the point
here is that not only is Trump saying he
wanted Pence to overturn the election
and we're gonna we've learned more about
this in the last 48 hours he actually
thinks maybe there should even be an
investigation into Penn so here is the
statement put out by Donald Trump
yesterday and again it's it reads like
one of these tweets and there's random
uh capitalization and all sorts of
different things quote so pathetic to
watch the unselect committee of
political hacks liars and traitors work
so feverishly to alter the Electoral
College act so that a vice president
cannot ensure the honest results of the
election when just one year ago they
said the vice president has absolutely
no right to ensure the true outcome or
results of an election in other words
they lied
and the vice president did have this
right or more pointedly could have sent
the votes back to various legislators
for reassessment after so much fraud and
irregularities were found now that's not
true we we looked already at the 12th
Amendment and the electoral vote act I
believe it's called of
1887 I think I I I'm now not remembering
the year I think it's 1887. we looked at
this earlier uh in the week
um it's already clear to 99.9 percent of
people that Mike Pence can't overturn
the election or do the things Trump
wanted him to do the reason that now the
language is is considering being updated
is specifically because of Bad actors
like Trump who are either deliberately
or out of ignorance misunderstanding
what the powers of the Pres of the Vice
President are in counting electoral
votes okay back to the statement as it
gets even crazier if it were sent back
to the legislators or if Nancy Pelosi
who is in charge of Capital Security
had taken my recommendation and
substantially increased security that's
a lie by the way there would have been
no January 6th as we know it now it's
fascinating to see Trump say on the one
hand the rioters are being treated
unfairly and he'll give pardons to some
of them and the sentences are unfair
while at the same time saying Nancy
Pelosi upping security could have
prevented it if they didn't do anything
wrong and they're being treated unfairly
and being punished when they shouldn't
be punished why is it we needed why
would security need to stop people from
doing something that wasn't a problem
it's completely incoherent as you can
tell
um and then Trump going on to say
therefore and this is like the key
whacked out line
therefore the unselect committee should
be investigating why Nancy Pelosi did
such a poor job of overseeing security
and why Mike Pence did not send back the
votes for recertification or approval in
that it has now been shown that he
clearly had the right to do so Trump is
out of his mind this is I mean he he
this is officially losing it
um it's also sort of a partial walk back
of his previous statement he now the
previous statement was Pence could have
overturned it
he seems to be walking it back by saying
what Pence could and should have done is
send it back to the States for
recertification Pence also can't do that
but it is a walk back of that original
statement which was even more unhinged
but the theme Here is it's always
someone else's responsibility in someone
else's fault
Pence is to blame Pelosi's to blame Brad
raffensberger is to blame Joe Biden
whoever people who allowed voting by
mail it's never I'm to blame because I
didn't get enough votes I didn't
convince enough people to vote for me
it's that's never the explanation and I
saw a funny comment on Reddit about this
sort of like faux Mirage alpha male
status of Donald Trump and it read what
kind of person listens to him and says
yes this is the big strong man as
opposed to this is what it sounds like
when my child loses a video game and
um this this is completely over the top
and Beyond the pale and this is the
world of a narcissist it's we've spoken
to psychologists and others before
everything is someone else's fault Trump
blames others for losing the election
Trump blames others for not fulfilling
what he believed or asked them to do in
terms of overturning the election and at
the end of the day
this will never change when you are this
deluded and narcissistic this is how
everything is seen through this lens
we'll have some of these uh statements
and clips that we looked at in this
segment on our Instagram which you can
find at davidpackman show
there are so many interesting and new
types of assets anyone could invest in
today wine sneakers artwork and many
others but the big question is which
ones actually make sense and that's why
I'm such a big fan of our sponsor alts
alts is a newsletter that will demystify
these investment markets and assets for
you whether we're talking video games or
baseball cards music rights comic books
alts does the analysis for you and it's
an analysis that nobody else is doing
they do extremely deep research to give
you valuable insights but alts is not
just about information it's also about
recommendations and you can check out
their excellent performance track record
on their website there are a ton of new
ways to diversify your portfolio
intelligently right now but you have to
know how to navigate them and understand
them and ALT makes it easy to understand
go sign up for free at davidpackman.com
alts the link is down below